ja ok ok ok soll er neben meinen haut
einen riesigen fehler setzen
die königin wird entscheiden eine
weitere folge minecraft hero zusammen
mit kates zu der so ne hai einen
wunderschönen tag kommt zu dem crafter
das geld es regnet ja sogar die
abgeschrieben ich soll den shader
auslassen ich weiß jetzt nicht was ihr
da meint dazu zu dem thema zu der
debatte shader oder nicht shader und ich
habe ihn jetzt mal ganz kurz da eine
begrüßung erstmal total schlecht zu
reden
bis zehnmal gestorben ja hier läuft ja
korrekt ich würde auch mal nicht gerne
business jetzt mal so eine frage für die
episode bin nicht derjenige der am
meisten in niveau gestorben ist zehn mal
nein ich hab ich hab die wenigsten
folgen die schafe gibt es ja auch noch
was vergessen
ja also ich habe relativ wenige folgen
aber ich glaub so ich bin schon ganz gut
dabei mit zehn mal unter 18 ist gut
dabei ich da er von mir wie am anfang
sagt sogar doch besser hier sechs mal
gestorben
relativ viel mehr als die hälfte hat
mehr tun als ich komischerweise däne hat
richtig viel butter hat auch schon
richtig viel so heftig nur ich bin halt
nicht so weit von den folgen weil ich
auch manchmal echt einfach so freiwillig
aussetzt weil ich dass er nicht so ein
projekt ist auch ich bin jetzt auch
irgendwie das ist ja nicht mal folge 60
bei mir dass es noch irgendwie 50er
bereich okay bei dir läuft auf jeden
fall ich hab mir steckt bei twitter
gemacht hashtag ananas wo ihr mir tweets
schreiben konnte
bezüglich lieber was ich machen soll und
da kam ein zweischneidiges schwert ist
aufgekommen zwar erstens ich soll an den
wegen hier so ein bisschen weiter bauen
also das alles mehr oder weniger
vernetzt ist allerdings
waren die personen nicht so klug weil es
ist eigentlich alles mehr oder weniger
vernetzt und dann wurde mir auch noch
gesagt dass ich mein haus bauen soll und
die essensausgabe endlich mal fertig
machen soll
hier macht das mal wieder nur wegen dir
gestorben was sagst du dreimal nur wegen
dir doch mal an luca ist berlin der
erstausgabe der stadt gemacht hätte
trotzdem die ganzen ärzte dass das waren
roman kienast ohne geschrieben ich
dachte mir ich sag dir das mal was so
manche von mir halten
ach so bei die stadt deswegen mir ist
also irgend kommentar als du geschrieben
wurde hat auch gleich irgendwie weiter
um salat sondern sand sonne
essensausgabe in statt blau wird
natürlich dem doch sehr viel helfen der
5000 blöcke von uns entfernt ist
zweitens nicht michael letzten episode
das hast du nicht mitbekommen weil du
dich nicht informiert tschuldigung in
meiner letzten episode bin ich in die
stadt rein gelaufen und hatte dann auch
schon brot aus der kiste von soldaten
gestorben in dem moment wo ich dieses
brot zu meinem mund geführt habe altern
ist rassistisch ja wie gesagt also bei
mir bei mir läuft das alles auf jeden
fall bei dir recht heftig merkt man
schon bald muss man die müll links auf
man ihm sonst ihre gerade ein bisschen
127 level und ich werde mir
wahrscheinlich in dieser folge ein frost
im bau machen was man nämlich auch
geschrieben wurde von ender games 3
interessanter name wollte vw schon
gemacht filke die hat auch rostock oder
down france bleu du bist nicht mehr
individuell
ich bin nicht mehr so sitzt daher geile
mich als mainstream im endspiel mit
frost pofalla ganz gleich welchen france
fordern auch verzaubern
weil das geile an diesem france paris
halt einfach dass du dir in bogen halt
hast und du kannst den gegner hat
einfrieren weil wie der name das halt
schon mehr oder weniger und das geil an
diesem 1 frieden ist einfach dass der
gegner sich hat nicht mehr bewegen kann
und das ist halt gerade so geil weil
wenn du dann ersten frost ball quasi auf
einen schießt und dann mit crystal ball
das ist einfach richtig richtig heiß vor
allem beim ein christ aber auch alle
möglichen verzögerungen drauf hat also
ich werde jetzt eben gucken wie man
einen oder was habe ich noch hinten drin
stehen in meiner exe-datei währenddessen
ein bisschen währenddessen irgendwelche
golems töten weil ich habe keine ich
habe mich braucht mehr setzen
doch messi ich habe eine menge essenzen
also ich habe sieben electric stuff ja
dass das buch ich habe keine elektrische
starten genau deswegen diese ganzen
pearc wodka kennedy brauche ich alles
letztlich so wie du dass ich jetzt
wieder ankommen sogar kannst du mir
einklinken
boah habe ich nie gemacht
ich gebe mir das ist ja wie soll ich
verwechsle ich bei ihr seid beide ein
bisschen jahr gebeten hatte ich f480
oder gar nicht erzählt jetzt möchte ich
kurz unterbrechen
ich bin übrigens jetzt du weißt es gibt
den untergrund ja so kann zwar mein haus
rangehen und kannst dort das schild
lesen
weißt du wo mein haus ist thorsten haus
war ich fühle mich hier nicht kommen
konnte der stadt ja klar
in der stadt ich komme aber ich bin in
meiner in meiner in meinem kind of skate
bin ich drin
ich komme ich komme kurz du dir über
luca bleibt ruhig wurde noch kurz eine
runde dauert ja nur zwei minuten und
dann hat sich das ich bin da besser mal
im haus wenn du diese verdammte hölle da
unten hast also diese unglaublich schön
gestaltete höhle das ist fast ein schock
aber namens denke ich die höhe dann
weißt du nicht du bist so moment ein tor
fällt
ich komme am horizont da ich guck da
gibt es das ist der eingang zu meinem
aus dass ich auch mal schön und da kann
sie das schild lesen über grund quartier
mit über grund also ich finde es in der
namensgebung auf jeden fall unglaublich
kreativ geht bin ich doch das war ein
vorschlag auf twitter als ich andauernd
witze über simons
wunderschön untergrund gebracht aber das
liebe hey warum nicht in über grund
gründen und erlaubt du ja das kann ich
auch
simon war auf dem server als käfer nicht
darauf an und sie man wollte uns
angreifen wenn wir nicht so mitglied
werden vom untergrund deswegen am mega
event mitglied und kämpft ist glaub ich
sogar wichtiges mitglied weil kef hat
jetzt da auch schon gefasst gebaut und
zwar alles ich will aber irgendwie
nichtmitgliedes untergrund sein aber ich
will trotzdem die diktatur von kim jong
il nach stürzen
ich weiß noch nicht wo sich der über
grund positioniert dass mich noch mit
den restlichen mitgliedern absprechen
da ist uns noch nicht so einig aber es
gibt die lokale position oder die
gesellschaftliche position
gesellschaftliche position ob wir jetzt
für den diktator sind oder für den
untergrund oder was ganz eigenes derzeit
sind wir die schweiz ja das haben so
entschieden in dem mitglieder votum und
das dass das bleibt erst mal so wir
wären ja schauen also heute wird
höchstwahrscheinlich ein livestream
stattfinden bei dem der kunde nicht
dabei ist weil schlecht das internet
zone selbst als ein anders
das wird mit den muslimen und dem song
beyond mal gucken vielleicht wäre ich
daher gefragt hey wo wir positioniert
sich die aktuell stärkste macht in jever
über grund alter hier ist ein blödes
skelett wieder das stört mich wieder
okay das bitte hilf mir ich mache ich
gleich
sobald ich muss immer erst mal was zu
essen weil ich überhaupt gab volkes muss
zuerst mitzunehmen ich wollte auf eine
große reise gehen
das ist ein klacks geleert da steht sie
ganz einfach der mob falle das ist
richtig stark aber zieht mich nicht mehr
das ist ich hab ja oh ich hab magic
essenzen ich habe sie gefunden ja das
will ich bestimmt schon 8000 mal in die
kommentare geschrieben
in den letzten episoden aber leute man
sieht halt nicht immer alles wenn man
blind ist ja das muss irgendwie nebenbei
euch euch denken so ich werde jetzt ganz
kurz die sachen holen die ich für so
einen verdammten france brauchen und
zwar muss sich dafür erst mal meinen
chocobo holen
das musst du tun wir wollten mich auch
gesagt dass ich beim zu holen
die show aussehen soll und das ist
irgendwie viel mehr dann bringt es ist
nicht mehr so verbuggt mal wenn ein
ähnlicher fälle fifa mag jetzt habe ich
die skater alles egal
ich habe die fifa und ein goldenes show
gewonnen wenn ich beide seiten hatten
bin ich so unglaublich schnell
ich bin einmal vom server deswegen
geflogen weil ich so schnell was soll
man gar nicht stand mal stand bei da
sich das nehme ich wollte ja auch ab
was überlegt wie die farmer die scale
arme und lucas mutter ins bett
letzteres entschieden und danach die
skater gekostet okay das auf jeden fall
fresh es bräuchte noch seite dann habe
ich den boden achter noch einen billig
und seite müsste ich glaube ich habe
dann schaffe ich in dieser folge einen
frost boonen den smi titel schreiben
france 2
das jetzt wieder max alter von wales
titel fand ich ganz gut zum frost das
hat etwas hatte geschrieben
frost einfach höher sein soll also das
trifft's halt aufwendig ist direkt auf
jeden fall
wir haben jetzt hier phoenix fehler
turbo für euch hardtop ich verbrenne
einfach mal meinen ganzen kisten ändert
so viel scheiße drin die ich gar nicht
brauche das ist so heftig
man kann auch irgendwie auch alles mit
einem ja stimmt jetzt ausgefüllt mit 1
liegt damit braucht man also blöcke ab
oder sollte man fast immer das ja voll
praktisch mit links liegt blöcke abbauen
hast hast du das alles so auf einmal
rüber geht was du das nicht wenn du bist
die leertaste und links liegen da geht
alles auf einmal über das wort praktisch
geht nicht bei mir
wir gehen aus ich bin noch gar nicht
dann habe ich herausgefunden mit shift
quasi so seien seien crafting zeug malen
kann ich bin da immer sehr schnell drin
denn so was ja in unserem haus finden
bisschen richtig guten als richtig
heraus finde bin ein richtiger
herausfindet ich informiere mich über
nichts ich mache einfach so habe ich
jetzt endlich mal alles hier haben ich
brauch ewigkeiten bissig und es hat
gleich hab ich gar keine zeit bei weg zu
gehen locker macht doch mal schneller
bist denn du doch gar nicht erzeugt man
führungsfehler weggeschmissen ist auch
egal dass ich stark dieses glück
verfolgt meldete mich die schicke
schwede geschehe hieß das einmal ab und
direkte habe ich zweieinhalb herzen
verloren mein ganzer bildschirme schwarz
ich kann mir gar nichts brauchten hier
romano
beide sind meine seite findet auch nicht
doch das gleicht sich nicht oder
deftigen stellen kann aber das ist man
kann auch irgendwie wir suchen noch nach
phoenix feder und irgendwie irgendwie
kann man suchen in den inventaren ja du
musst doppelklick machen auf die
suchagenten nach einer seite das sind
schon mal drei ich brauche aber 6455
viertel okay 6 jetzt noch ein mal gucken
hier ist drin schön gut weil die will
ich mich beibehalten weil dann sterbe
ich anders nicht so schnell
danke danke schön für den tipp ich werde
hier noch richtig zum profi nur wegen
dir du dieses böse skelett dass mich die
ganze zeit abschießen
auch die du kennst du behältst diese
miniatur herzen die sonne voll krass
sein
ja ich könnte mir theoretisch wir machen
aber mir fehlt einfach diese scheiß
aluminium an das braucht muss man
einfach finden
also das ist nicht aufwendig irgendwie
zu bekommen man muss einfach nur dafür
ganz viel aluminium büsche es gibt
aluminium und das muss man ja alles
erstmal einschmelzen und in einem dieser
speziellen crafting dinge die mit diesem
einen mod dazu kommen muss man das ja
basteln das war ich so alles oder
ich weiß das alles natürlich natürlich
selbstverständlich was wäre ein referat
auch noch nicht habe gehalten in der
schule ja mit mit powerpoint alles war
dann auch dementsprechend dann eine 5
lief es über exit scheiße scheiße latina
es regt mich gar nichts mehr ich habe
ich habe ja schon electric stäbe
gekostet muss jetzt eigentlich gar nicht
mehr jagen gehen habe ich mache noch
irgendwas in der episode sieht ja was
ich machen muss dass ihr euch nicht
erzählen ihr seid ihr alle schlau sind
irgendwie alle live dabei auch alle live
dabei in dem fall auch noch ich habe
lang lang kein hebel mehr aufgenommen
durch
weißt du nicht auch was von dem star die
zuschauer sind vielleicht etwas wo du
dich gerade befindest man youtube dass
so eine plattform im internet
im moment lassen künftig heißen euro da
kann nicht sein jetzt kann ich nicht
dazu den kisten gehen mal da diese
scheiß gelehrt wache schieben wo ist das
so wenn ich mal gucken ich komme ich
komme mit bei cap im haus wahlkämpfe im
haus ehrgeiz 24 fps 20 das da muss ich
ein schlingel der schein hat da als die
richtig ab wieder würde ich gleich alles
schwarz für die direkt zwei herzen
ja also diese herzen verlieren statt mir
nicht so aber dieses schwarz machen
stört nicht ich mag es nicht wenn ich
gewollt ein legia bogen dran wenn ich
irgendwo gezeugt dabei hätte was ich
gerade nicht ab ja er hat ihn auf jeden
fall nur kurz ab oder nutzen direkt dass
ich mir hier kurz dann den bogen machen
kann
ja ja ja ich habe nur das gefühl ich
stehe da kriegt auch jedes mal mehr
erleben dass vor der op babo ja das
behindert man ja kannst du mir einen
pfeil oder somit bringen ich habe nichts
vom einen bogen raus drin
warte ich mal eben einen frost bogen
dann fick ich denn hier sind schön
so steckt da denn stadtrat ist da
draußen ich bin dumm ich hab mein eis
kam weggeschmissen abgeholt habe die
pässe logo du schlingel wo bist du ich
hab mir verloren sogar egal das ist gut
wenn er weg ist
ich muss mir kurz eis holen da kann doch
nicht sein
eigentlich bringt es ja vor nicht doch
das bringt gib mir reifen 21 habe ich
zwar theoretisch müssten wir die richtig
dreckige kraft und verzaubert folgen wir
sind so richtig die post ab wir sind
richtig produktiv produktiv nicht
irgendjemand bei wem stanzen kommend
einem halt stand drin endlich bist du
wieder produktiv mit ca dass ich mir
wohl produktive rechtschreiben lehre das
wäre auch was was dem zuschauer ein
bisschen geholfen hätte alter vater
ich hatte gerade instant plötzlich war
ich auf drei herzen runter
verzieh dich lieber aber kein witz ihr
alter was geht denn was ist das für dich
machen es ist der ist für behinderte so
infiniti kriegt der 32 haben den du eben
ihm machst den kriegst du glaub ich
direkt auf dich wieder portiert weil ich
habe jetzt einen bogen draufgezogen das
zieht halt ganz schön eigentlich darf
ich einmal kurz in den cross mountain
macht eigentlich keinen schaden und den
effekt einfach noch wegen des new yorker
etwas passiert man macht noch mal ohne
vielleicht bin ich irgendwas moment
lohnes ich bin ich bin langsam glaub ich
nicht fliegen ist auch langsamer das ist
voll das ist wohl gut ja ich dachte er
rast gold tieren an breaking drei
draufgepackt
es kommt ja da niemand aber ich kann die
maus macht mal dieser scheiß skelette
egal das haben die nächsten einfach das
problem mit dem das geht mir auf
verlaufen sagt diese skelette dahin
steht schon wieder
du kriegst mega den schaden ich probiere
noch mal an ihren moment trifft die dann
treffe ich gesichts verlesen werden
welches zu cobo hall findet auch relativ
beleidigen falls alle verwandeln
unterliegen sind wie in chaco was egal
du kennst du musst auch mal zu unserer
königin beten jetzt bin ich auf
gesichtsfeld drauf geschrieben
dabei wollte ich nur heilen kämpfen muss
auch mal unser und zu unserer königin
beten ich hab gesagt - ja das hab ich
auch gewonnen ich weiß gar nicht wo mich
auf die ansprache reagiert wäre kein
problem
auf jeden namen aber ganz ehrlich wenn
solche massen konfis haben dann ist
jetzt ein holzblock in holzbriketts
mildes dann war hast du richtig letzter
weg da habe ich noch knappe sich
hingesetzt könnte sollen jetzt hierhin
studieren holzblock
als mann gottes das die kollegen kommen
die her du hast ja aber nicht gesetzt
ist eine alte oma das macht reich
schaden
die wenig gezaubert hat in einer rüstung
auf an breaking 2 und so nicht so nicht
sonderlich weit muss ich machen das was
auch ecken drei visionen angehen wird
natürlich mal da nicht mal was nadine
anschluss darfst du dich mal heftig mit
dem crystal ball aber ich glaube der ist
auch nicht heftig jedoch zwei macht er
ich will mich wirklich ob die guck mal
wie schnell man mit dem christbaum
schießen kann
das ist komplett angespannt
man kann mit ihm halt viel schneller
schießen als pädagogen deswegen wurde
mehrfach geschrieben ich soll die
verzauberung vom labor unternehmen weil
mit belegen kann es ja zwei drei pfeile
schießen aber es trifft immer nur einer
außerdem jüngsten direkt wenn du
verstehst dann bringt das hat zunächst
erholen witz oder so habt ihr so so so
und unsere königin ja horsten knicks
machen wenn du vor sieg ist optimal
irgendwas knicks du musst knicks
du musst dich was fragen haben eine
magische miesmuschel app die soiree am
start oder was natürlich kinos gehöre
nun darf jetzt irgendwas fragen und ich
ziehen dann hier die schnur ich habe
sowieso alles ohne ende aber ich frage
jetzt was ja ja davon aus orakel fragen
stellen
unsere königin wir sollten vielleicht
nochmal falle ausfällt auch schnell
vielleicht hat es dann nicht mehr
ja es ist so es ist glaube ich die mob
falle ohne ende und irgendwie haben und
mein pc und alles was dazugehört und
hätte ich nach derzeitigen gegenseitig
töten soll ja nun ja als irgendetwas
fragen zum beispiel zum beispiel ich
habe letztes mal ganz ganz viel schnee
eingesammelt und wollte und in unserer
kompletten stadt ist hier überall hier
ist er gras wo wir also drauf laufen
könne wollte ich komplett aus einem
anderen material machen weil das hat
noch keine stadt wollte ich einfach aus
schnee machen also schnee statt die
stars wenn mal schnee direkt nebenan da
hinten und dann habe ich die königin
angefragt nachdem ich das alles gefilmt
habe darf ich das dann als schnee machen
und die man einfach nein machen
du kannst noch einmal für frage also ich
frage lieber königin soll ich dich noch
mal reiten liebe königin soll solle doch
lieber mal runter gehen von dir ja es
liegt nicht auf der hand soll
runtergehen
ja da hast du eine frage bezüglich bau
und kräften irgendwas ja dass man
überlegen soll ich lukas haus soll ich
lebe lukas haus einen riesigen penis
errichten
nein das ist kacke das ist passiert zum
stadtbild soll das was das trau dass ich
nicht dass das ok ok soll neben meinem
haus einen riesigen pläne setzen
oh mein gott die königin wird
entscheiden ob ich das noch mache ich
muss das jetzt eigentlich machen
gleich beginnt ist das einfach alle
antworten von die gegen mich sind die
app zeigen damit ich auch immer die
bühne getragen kann vor allem ich habe
hier aktiviert was ich zeig euch mal den
einstellungen
ich hab das jetzt hier irgendwie nicht
schluss machen
an einer mutig habe negativ und positiv
aktiviert neutral habe ich ausgelassen
es kommt einfach nur gegen mich nur
gegen mich aber wir müssen jetzt noch
ein bisschen den amokfahrer ein bisschen
herum schlagen damit nicht verstellen
gefährlich wirds nicht machen diese
müssten vielleicht mal ausmachen oder
wie wäre das mal ich hab das schon
ausgemacht und schießt ja die ganze zeit
mit meinem bogen rhein wo man immer
nicht mal so eine sperre aus weil damit
kann man so ein massen angriff machen
müssen das blöde skelett das kommt
bestimmt irgendwann von hinten und
bremst uns alle ins gesicht ja damals
nicht fragen ob du mal nach dem skelett
gucken kannst du mal ich hab das also
ich hab das ganze ding verbraucht mit
einem schlag ja das ist auch krass das
übel an statt rot ist es ja noch
schlimmer wenn man da entlang läuft dann
bekommst du direkt irgendwie 211 ps
das ist richtig krass ehrlich war das
heftig aber weiss statt rot ist auch so
dass selbst wenn man da die monster
falle benutzt dass man die ganze zeit
die heftigsten erfahrungen bekommt aber
der server einfach mal für ein paar
minuten heftig ihm aus dem weg oder was
okay ich wahrscheinlich macht da schon
zwei jahre erfahrung oder ende aber es
ist cool ist cool passt alles easy
wahrscheinlich welche die alten leute
also das ist nicht kaputt gegangen das
wort mir einfach uns und viel
weggenommen
das erklärt alles moment es soll ich
vielleicht ich einfach mal die ordnung
zerstören luca aber wir wer wir
überziehen ganz dreckig wenn wir jetzt
weitermachen glaube ich also jedenfalls
laut meiner zeit anzeige sind jetzt auch
mal durch ich werde jetzt auch eine
folge alleine aufnehmen für morgen
danone kinos weil david livestream und
bildern werden besser sagen wenn es euch
gefallen hat könnte ich eine bewertung
lassen nach europa beiden videos
verdammt noch mal nur bei den upfronts
einer episode die freude wieder angenäht
dann beim nächsten mal wieder nicht